hey we're getting drunk it's Kaylee's
that's Iraq congratulations Kayla I
can't believe it how much time we went
out have a forgiveness to to the dawn
we're going now we were [ __ ] chilling
and I just got back to the hotel and and
and and Jessica sucker guys day I
honestly I'm just so happy for [ __ ]
Kelly to be a fighting guy if it's
Jessica that was the Sun guy's dick in
it she doesn't have a boyfriend
incas Kelly is the one that wants to do
what the [ __ ] she was to do but she
can't cuz she's a mare it's okay
I don't [ __ ] care if you're gonna
target if you're gonna be Kaylee and you
talked about Jessica tell her what to do
be because we all know deep do we all
know that what Kim isn't is a cannibal
[ __ ] Kaylee trust no [ __ ] yeah a little
[ __ ] you never knows in that [ __ ] with
you yeah yeah you big bad [ __ ] just
kids your friend and you putting her in
a party you're putting your party so
it's good
I'll tell you what the focus he did
she knows your brother she knows your
brother she she didn't [ __ ] him on it
honestly she [ __ ] it she suck his
dick for a jacket and now locked out
what the [ __ ] is a documentary for kid